what by the way what if every morning
was like oh it is pet talk no the yeah I
was like inspiring I know I know so you
moved you moved to a farm since the last
time I saw you yes which I live on a
ranch so I love that lifestyle have you
ever lived on a farm or man I that's my
dream it really my dream it was mine too
and I bought it well something tells me
something tells me when you have a dream
you make it happen oh no yeah yeah I
want chickens I want a I want a tractor
I want a cop pipe I want a shotgun it's
I I can get you all those things I can
too we are your people and probably so
can Amazon but it is it's amazing as you
know uh just the
interconnectivity of life as you
know wait a minute that's a horse in
your house that's a goat that's a goat
is that aan oh yeah there's our horse oh
that is a horse I missed the horse I saw
the goat
that's that's my
office your office you have the
miniature miniature I love it we were
doing a a big board meeting for for for
brothers Bond yeah oh for the bourbon
yeah yeah yeah for the bourbon a horse
and and all and Paul Paul Wesley we were
on this big call with all the heads of
of Brothers Bond and all of a sudden
Delilah the goat walks by and Paul went
is that a goat I said yeah yeah it's
Delila she's usually in a diaper and
then
and then
lucky and then and then our mini horse
walks by and uh everyone just stopped
and they went can what is going on in
your house but it's so special and for
my you know for our little one to be
able to live like that yeah it makes for
such a full
[Music]
life
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home